البدايه حول الموسيقي العبقري احد اعظم
الملحدين على الاطلاق
فبعد مضيمه يقرب من 200 عام على وفاته كشف
بحث لجامعه عن معلومات جديده حول وفاه
المؤلف الموسيقي الالماني
خمس خصلات شعر كانت كفيله لتوصل العلماء
الى تسلسل للجينوم الخاص به الدراسه التي
نشرت نتائجها في مجالات كورن بيولوجي
العلميه كشفت عن استعداد لرقيقه ولد
بيتهوفن للاصابه بامراض الكبد فضلا عن
اصابته بفيروس التهاب الكبد من النوع في
اواخر عمره وهما عاملان من المحتمل ان
يكون قد ساهم في وفاته على الارجح لكن لم
يتمكن الباحثون من شرح سبب اصابته بالصمم
التدريجي والذي تسبب في الكثير من الالم
في حياته
وربما هذا الكشف يحقق وصيه بيتهوفن التي
اعرب فيها عام 1802 عن رغبته في توصيف
مرضته بعد وفاته